okay nice game
and what else do we have
uh well we have some guy
with my picture so let's give him
let's give him a chance and start with
one e4
some micellar from russia russians are
always tough
whatever ratings they have okay let's
try the lopez
he goes for berlin you should never play
berlin having my picture
okay let's go d3
and goes d6 okay this is a slow approach
there is nothing wrong with that
obviously okay let's just castle
bishop g4 while
this is aggressive
yeah so the point of this plan is to get
some g5
play no he just castles but then i think
it doesn't make a lot of sense
white wall simply brings knight to g3
and he has a bishop on h5
looks a little bit stupid to me okay he
goes b5 i don't know which square is
better let's go to b3 for instance
bishop c2 was also decent but yeah you
don't spend
more than three three seconds making
such decisions and blades
so yeah now he can go c5 and then we
just go knight f1
and yeah continue our plan
i think black would be completely fine
with the bishop on e6 instead of h5 but
uh
with a bishop on like h5 or g6
it's a little bit uh yeah it's a little
bit
awkward for him so it's not doing much
there in fact and
yeah somehow white is just slightly
better
or maybe not even slightly i don't know
so he goes before
which is logical
[Music]
so how should i place this
uh so we could try some some d4 plants
or we could just play it slow as well
okay let's play some bishop d2 for now
i would be very happy to play yeah
exactly so that's why he plays a5
but now at least we can move our bishop
back because with the pawn on e6 after b
should be three he would always have
knight a5
and that would be a little bit
unpleasant now at least our
last color bishop is perfectly placed on
this diagonal
so i can even move it to c4
and just to make it a little bit more
more comfortable for us
then the next stage of of a plan is
normally knight h4 or knight h2
so the thing is that we should improve
slowly
and we should not blunder d5 okay let's
go knight h4
so knight xc4 runs into knight takes g6
and knight takes e7 check
seems to work
knight seven was a little bit mysterious
probably his idea is knight c
followed by knight b6 but it feels a bit
slow and then
even if he gets this we just go bishop
b5 and
it's not obvious why why would he need
it
that much
now he goes knight e8
which is a little bit mysterious as well
okay let's bring this knight to f5
now it's very simple for white we just
go queen g4 h4
maybe f4 even so yeah it's a symmetrical
position where uh
white pieces are much better placed and
it's very easy to play
still it's sort of solid for black i
mean you don't lose this in
three moves okay let's go queen f3
improve the queen
uh some bishop g5 could be our next move
h4h5 is also on the idea
it goes 96 back so we could play
literally anything here
um
let's bring the rook to d1 first maybe
we'll go d4 one day and it will help us
so now he goes knight d8 so he wants to
bring the knight to six which is a
decent square indeed
that makes sense okay let's keep coming
with h4
and try to clarify what's his decision
at the king side
so it's either h6 or he simply allows h5
takes on f5 and
keeps suffering both are
quite unpleasant he goes h5 which is
also possible
but then i thought we'd just go bishop
g5 take on f6 and collect h5
yeah there is nothing wrong with that it
seems
so i can just take on f6 and take an h5
for my notes
so it's a healthy pawn so far but a4 is
hanging in some lines
which doesn't make a lot of a difference
i would say so even if we lose it i mean
it's still um
quite unpleasant for black to face all
the straights coming
coming at the king side
so he takes we take back knight f4 now i
believe we just go queen g4
threatening knight h6 check
and then we go g3 chasing the knight
away yeah he goes 96 himself okay
fine um
yeah now it's um unbelievably
comfortable for us
we can just improve slowly let's start
with g3
it goes g6
let's just brings knight to d5
i mean we probably had uh something more
more convincing but i just don't see
single reason too
you have to be in hurry for white
okay h5 looks normal
knight g7 we can just take on g6
knight takes g4
there is no even point to take on f7
we can just improve slow looking g2 rook
h1
everything is coming
now i guess we could go with four
then if he takes twice we'll have knight
f6 check
and otherwise um yeah exactly this rook
is coming to each one
so he will probably end up being made
here yeah exactly
so we take one f7 and rookie chases
checkmate
okay thanks
[Music]
um
yeah let me let me choose opponent so
let's play this guy